In the last section,
we saw that the motif enumeration
algorithm that we proposed had a flaw:
It assumed that the motif
that we are looking for
must occur in every string in the
collection of strings under consideration,
which is not necessarily true
in biological applications.
As an alternative, our plan is to assign
a score to a given collection of k-mers
chosen from the strings.
So, say that we have collected
such a set of k-mers,
which we call Motifs,
represented here as a matrix.
We indicate the most frequent nucleotide
in each column of this matrix
by a capital letter,
breaking ties arbitrarily.
So note that positions two and three in
the motif matrix are the most conserved.
Nucleotide G occurs in these
positions in every k-mer,
whereas position ten, at the end of
the motif matrix, is the least conserved.
A common method of visualizing a motif
matrix is with a motif logo, in which
the size of the nucleotide correlates with
how often it occurs in the motif matrix.
Taking the capital letter in each column,
construct a consensus string for
this particular choice of k-mers that will
also provide us with a candidate motif.
Our goal then is to choose k-mers
from the underlying strings, so
that they produce the most
conserved motif matrix.
Then, simply take the consensus string
as our desired biological motif.
We therefore are going to define
the score of the motif matrix
as simply the number of
lowercase letters in the matrix.
Counting the number of lowercase
letters column by column,
we see that the score for
this choice of motifs is equal to 30.
We can now restate our goal as
choosing a collection of k-mers
from the underlying strings in
order to minimize this score.
So we now have a more appropriate
computational problem,
which we call the Motif Finding Problem.
A brute force algorithm for
the Motif Finding Problem would simply
consider every possible choice of
k-mers to form a motif matrix and
then simply take a collection of
k-mers having the lowest score.
But, as with any brute force approach,
we need to ask ourselves
how fast this algorithm is.
Assuming that there are, say, t strings
under consideration, all of length n,
then there are (n-k+1)^t
such possibilities for
how to form a motif matrix.
Then, scoring the matrix
requires k*t steps.
So, assuming that k is much smaller
than n, as is the case in practice,
the overall running time of this approach
is approximately O(n^t * k*t).
Now, the n^t term means
that this algorithm is useless for
practical values of n and t, and so
we're going to need a faster algorithm.
So, to improve on our existing
brute force approach,
we will rethink the motif finding problem.
Specifically, I've noted here that,
when we choose the motif matrix,
it automatically gives
us a consensus string.
Our new approach will be to choose
the consensus string first,
then look for a motif matrix that
scores best against this consensus.
How do we achieve this?
Well, until now, we have been scoring
the motif matrix column-by-column.
However, we could just as easily compute
the number of lower case symbols on
the motif matrix row-by-row.
I want you to note that the number
of lower case symbols in a row
is equal to the number of symbols in
that row that don't match the consensus,
which we know as the Hamming Distance
between that row and the consensus string.
As a result, the score of
the motifs matrix is just the sum
Hamming Distances between each string
in the matrix and the consensus string,
which we're going to write as
d(Consensus(Motifs), Motifs).
This discussion now leads us to
the equivalent Motif Finding Problem,
in which we are looking for a pattern
that will serve as our consensus string,
i.e., a pattern that minimizes
the distance to motifs
over all choices of motifs
in the underlying strings.
It may still seem that we have not
made our work any easier though,
since we are now looking for a pattern
in addition to a collection of motifs,
whereas before we just looked for
a collection of motifs.
However, we will see in the next section
that we don't need to search through every
possible choice of motifs in order
to find an optimal consensus string,
which is what we're looking for.